[Music]
troy
have you started shopping for your suit
yet
you know i've received a lot of
recommendations of different brand names
and
really the only store that i know in my
hometown is walmart
honestly it's just so lovely that people
are loving the movie we were such a
close cast and this movie was so special
to make so the fact that people are
enjoying it and yeah nominating it is
just the best feeling and i'm so
grateful to everybody
[Music]
what would it mean for you uh and for
the deaf community if koda won best
picture at the oscars
i'm sure that people in the deaf
community would just feel thrilled and
be able to share that feeling and
celebrate together and my daughter
mentioned she's a real life coda and she
said it's so cool to see deaf and
hearing people collaborate together our
film bridges two worlds
in one picture and so it's it's a thrill
i can't stay with you for the rest of my
life
when did you know that this was gonna be
something really special it's a really
good question
the minute i met marley troy and daniel
and we all just got on and we all were a
family and we kind of had that dynamic
if you're making something that is
making people on set laugh and cry then
you're making something very special
because i think blaster and peers are an
irresistible double act